the countdown to Thanksgiving is on and
you know that means hours worth of
cooking but if you aren't careful
experts say all that work in the kitchen
could aggravate carpal tunnel paint
Victoria Saha spoke with local doctors
on tips to protect your hands
when you think of Thanksgiving you think
of the giant turkey and the delicious
sides that follow but before you get to
dig in there's lots of work that needs
to be done in the kitchen and for the
cook that means your hands and arms are
busy by the end of the night you could
be feeling numbness tingling and wrist
pain Dr Ryan grabo says at this time of
year is the perfect recipe for a carpal
tunnel pain we do have patients who come
in right after holidays or in prep for
holidays you're saying yeah I've been
making bread or cookies because I sent
them all over the country with my family
and now I'm having numbers continuing
but he says while you're in the middle
of chopping garnishing and mixing find
some time to do a couple of hand
stretches stretching wrist back for
about a minute bringing it down for
about a minute with your arm fully
extended this not only helps your carpal
tunnel but people have heard of tennis
elbow and golfers elbow Dr grumbo
recommends if you're someone that's
susceptible to wrist pain you could wear
a splint or brace while you're cooking
Victoria Saha eight news now the the
doctor says when it comes to carving
your turkey you'll want to put less
pressure on your hands by making sure
you have a sharp knife that will do the
majority of the work for you